استشهد اخوي
312 استشهد في الشيخ زايد ضرب وهو في
السياره افناه عند الاندونيسي في الشيخ
زايد بين المدرستين في م كانه مقبره
جماعيه عشان مؤقت عبين ما تخلص الحرب
حطيناها هناك عند الاندونيسي ما ده ايام
يومين ثلاثه اسبوع اسبوعين اللي هو خشوا
علينا بي ما قدرناش نعمل اي حاجه احنا
احنا الكوييسين اللي عايشين طلعنا شردنا
على مكان اللجوء اللي هو عند ابو زيتون
عند
المعسكر بعد اسبوع اسبوعين طولوا في الحر
والبريه تتهم لما قدرنا نروح نصل عرفنا ان
اياد موجود رحنا دورنا عليه م لقيناه نا
ندور ونبحك هان وهان لقينا يد اخوي بس من
بين المقبره كلها هي بس لحال يد لقيناه
اجوا اليهود نبشوا عنا في في المقبره عند
الشيخ زايد واخذ الجت عشان اخوي كان مزوي
شويه حطيناه في القرنه احنا ما شافهوش
الحمد لله وين المسلمين فيش مسلمين وينهم
واحد يهودي يجي يفح قبر بالجرافه مش بديه
احنا احنا لما ندفن ميت اقل من راحتنا
بدفنه يجي هو في الجرافه ينتش الجدد كلهن
ولما جينا على المقبره ندفنه كانت طريق
صعبه شويه ما قدرنا نمشي فيه نحطه على توك
توك ولا حاجه حطيناه شويه على توك توك ما
قدرش يكمل التوك توك تبعيش ليش نزلت من
التوك توك ليش نزلت من التوك توك عشان فيش
طريق الطريق مسكره
وصلنا لمقبره ودفنا جنب ابن عمي الثاني
محمد
اسامه